o geniol y no tenía previsto pasar su
domingo sola en su oficina a partir de
este lunes su empresa como todas las
otras tendrá que acelerar el ritmo del
teletrabajo de tres a cuatro días por
semana como mínimo para limitar el auge
de contagios algo que obliga a esta
directora ejecutiva a planificar el
regreso de vacaciones
y nosotros esperamos a que haya un 10
por ciento de efectivos contagiados al
mismo tiempo el reto es evitar que
contagien a todos nuestros empleados de
lo contrario tendríamos un riesgo por
ello hemos aplicado mucho el teletrabajo
como todas las empresas es también se
busca limitar los contagios en las
escuelas con nuevas reglas para hacer
frente al contacto con un caso positivo
se autoriza el ingreso a las aulas
después de haber obtenido un resultado
negativo en una prueba pcr de antígenos
pero habrá que someterse de nuevo a un
test dos días después y luego cuatro
días después un control suplementario
que podrá ser realizado por los padres
en casa
serás es una situación que es así nos
tenemos que adaptar
no estoy muy a favor de que los niños
estén vacunados por lo tanto mientras
les podamos hacer pruebas y proceder de
esa manera está bien a sanz gobierno la
mascarilla pasa a ser obligatoria para
los niños mayores de 6 años algo que ya
estaba en vigor para los adultos
llevarlo en la nariz así como el
transporte público consecuencia
prohibido comer a bordo el gobierno
habría preferido aprobar esta medida el
pasado fin de semana de gran tráfico
para aplicar una norma que aún genera
dudas
muy feas y yo viajo nueve horas por eso
prefería hacerlo hoy domingo
nueva norma para las salas de
espectáculos el aforo se limita dos mil
espectadores solamente este circo
aparecido con capacidad para 14 mil 600
personas había vendido todo para los
próximos días y ahora debe repartir a
esos espectadores que hemos añadido
funciones y hemos notificado al público
a través de las redes sociales y la
gente se inscribió para las nuevas
funciones al final esto terminó sin
mayor dificultad de pases o para los
deportes y los espectáculos al aire
libre el aforo se reduce a cinco mil
personas